صفعه للهيمنه العالميه للدولار وقنبله
بوجه الاقتصاد الامريكي تمثلت في تخلي
الصين والبرازيل عن العمله الامريكيه
واستخدام عملتيهما المحليتين اليوان
والريال في تعاملاتهما التجاريه فما السبب
وراء هذه الخطوه وهل بات الدولار في خطر
الصين تعد اكبر منافسا اقتصادي للولايات
المتحده فيما تعد البرازيل شريكها التجاري
الاكبر وصاحبه اكبر اقتصاد في امريكا
اللاتينيه ففي عام 2022 وحده قدر التبادل
التجاري بين بكين وبرازيليا ب 150 مليار
دولار تقارير افادت بان هذه الخطوه ستعزز
التجاره الثنائيه بين البلدين بشكل اكبر
وتخفض التكاليف كما ستسهل الاستثمار في
المقابل خبراء قالوا ان من المبكر جدا
الحديث عن انهيار الدولار خصوصا انه يشكل
نحو 60% الاحتياطات البنوك المركزيه في
العالم ونحو 90% من سوق صرف العملات ليس
هذا فقط راى الخبراء ايضا ان الدولار
يحافظ على قوته طالما ان اسعار السلع
الرئيسيه كالنفط والمعادن الثمينه مرتبطه
به في الاسواق العالميه لكن هل هناك
تداعيات للخطوه الصينيه البرازيليه عالميا
تزايد التبادل بين الدول بعملات غير
الدولار من شانه ان يؤثر على مركزيه
العمله الامريكيه في النظام العالمي كاكثر
العملات استخداما وان يرفع عملات اخرى الى
المراكز الاولى فحط فبراير الماضي حافظت
العمله الصينيه على موقعها كخامس اكبر
العملات نشاطا في المدفوعات العالميه